the face time is over it isn't the same
if you want to you really want to get
even a hug I'm lost two members of my
family to this 1419 I'm pretty scared
right now young people the disrupt
silence and provide the benefits for
tomorrow I sent me out my new world is
one where people can come together that
kind of chaos we're seeing in American
cities is a direct result of a very
faulty policy of lacking people in their
homes we still don't know where this
coronavirus first made the jump to
humans
there's no cover there's no delay
China's in fact record is it clean
[Music]
a very good evening I'm Dermot Manor and
now over the course of this week I'm
going to be speaking to some of the
leading lights and culture politics
economics and science and tonight we're
joined by the former Foreign Secretary
David Miliband by Mary Robinson who was
the UN High Commissioner for Human
Rights and president of Ireland and
indeed now leads the fight for what she
calls climate justice we've also got the
historian professor Neil Ferguson who
thinks Kovach 19 could be here to stay
for a while we're also joined by China's
ambassador to the United Kingdom Luc
Xiao Ming now facing them a live virtual
studio audience from around the world
who will be asking questions about how
we can forge hope to forge a new future
we start tonight with the global
challenges and how the virus will
reshape our world at large the virus has
spread to every region of China
recognize a super Sperry event before it
goes explosive and declaring a public
health emergency of international
concern the whole of Italy will face the
most draconian restrictions since the
Second World War it is an empty is full
of people to pay off all self isolation
is a tsunami don't think that can't
happen everywhere else Boris Johnson has
tested positive for coronavirus and so
vice mate
the number of dead in New York is
climbing and the morgues are running out
of space the patients keep coming and
it's not just the elderly how is it
biblical
I see the disinfectant and is there a
way we can do something like that by
injection we're supposed to be
practicing social distancing it's really
difficult in a community like this
digging thousands upon thousands of
graves in the city of Sao Paulo
men women and children have bought for
many miles Mexico City's crematorium
dark coat there are full capacity
already
we may have won a few battles but we
have not run the war it's about doing
the sort of things that we take for
granted there was a sense of release and
a hope that perhaps the worst is over
across the world a planet in pandemic
paralysis is looking different I want to
bring in the first question from our
virtual audience Eamon what would you
like to ask this evening post pandemic
does the panel see an urgent need for
reform of global institutions such as
the UN World Health Organization and the
unit European Union or are we likely to
see an increase fragmentation between
member state participants I put three
things on the table straightaway first
of all we need a better a more
independent World Health Organization
the truth is its weaknesses reflect the
factors tied down by its membership
structure it needs to be more
independent secondly we need a better
funding and more independently funded
World Health Organization so that it's
able to carry out its work without
worrying what the member states who fund
it will say and thirdly and I think
critically we need a world health
organization that is more powerful that
it's able to do independent inspections
that it's able to partner with the
private sector more effectively as well
as with NGOs and I think if we can get
the reform of the World Health
Organization right it could set a
template for a wider set of institutions
that also need to be got right Neil
Ferguson and given that analysis of the
w-h-o and how its performed during this
crisis to US president Trump have a
point it's in China's pocket and he's
right to withdraw its funding by the
United States well I can't agree
with President Trump on this because
withdrawing the United States only
increases the probability that the w-h-o
will become but hold in to China or one
of the other great powers because let's
not kid ourselves with all due respect
my old friend David Miliband the
international order set up after world
war two was designed to be dominated by
the great past and we seem to be back to
Cold War only this time it's China in
the role of the Soviet Union it is not
politicization to ask for clear answers
from China to the question what happened
in December January we need to know we
still don't know where this coronavirus
first made the jump to humans except
that it was in Wuhan but whether it was
in a wet market or a laboratory we still
do not know although flights out of
Wuhan were restricted on the 23rd
flights continued from all the other
Chinese airports and they clearly
transported the virus to Europe as well
as to the United States and other
countries I'm very sorry
here so many cold war rhetoric from Manu
you know we can that we know each other
before but I don't know why you know he
is so interesting having a cold war with
the China I just want to let you know
China is not a formal Soviet Union you
being a historic union should have a
serious study of China you know I want
to put aside I can provide you with more
information more facts we have visited
24 reality check I will mail it to you I
just want to say we shouldn't talk to
the law played by de hecho we shouldn't
because tablet or spoke positively about
effort of China you know WH o is a very
important international organization we
have a Sandra Trent sir I just have to
bring you back to the Chinese
responsibility undoubtedly and we know
this that China was in denial about
kovat 19 for so long about animal to
human transmission about human to human
transition you didn't tell the world
soon enough I
I told you we lost no time in forming a
Chico you know this is a new variance
you have to be responsible you know it's
unknown to all of us
so either way you will need scientists
to study in a responsible way and
seriously once we like think we identify
this new where is 12 days after the
first report then we immediately report
to develop a job and share this
information whether country's relevant
countries there's no cover there's no
delay
China's record is a tree it can stand
the test of time and a history what I'm
also saying China first report the
barest it does not mean the virus
originated from China in terms of origin
I think is up to the scientists to
decide we conducted a wide-ranging poll
for this program of what the public
thinks about the future so let's share
it with you in our exclusive survey we
asked looking forward what is the
biggest issue that the world needs to
address now take this in because 33% 1/3
of those polled said the environment and
climate change were well ahead then of
the 15 percent less than how if we said
preventing future pandemics we need to
just go green go green with investment
jobs insulating houses and buildings and
also the biodiversity side the rewilding
the understanding of our link with
nature the the real need for the kind of
support that the young people in
particular get that indigenous people
have been telling us about for years
there's a lot of wisdom around if only
we'd listened to it let's turn to you
panel I get your arms ready again raise
your hands here's the question if you
trust your government to do the right
thing wherever you are do you trust your
government to do the right thing
Wow so about
four five hands in total there what's
that about 10% of you okay how many of
you trust Donald Trump to work with
other countries to build a better future
Donald Trump how many of you trust
Donald Trump to work with other
countries to build a better future well
and lots of shaking heads and no hands
raised what about the Chinese government
same question what do you think about
the Chinese government its ability to
work with other countries to build a
better future well perhaps a dozen of
you or so but I've got to ask the the
Ambassador finally on this this lack of
trust particularly with younger
generations where you are seeing that on
the streets of Hong Kong and the Chinese
states repression of those protesters
those seekers after democracy no it's
not the Chinese you know suppression
what is going on in Hong Kong is
violence you know it's a it's totally
it's a risk to the national security you
know it's the perpetrators storm the
department the electrical voice we call
it and they even put unfair the innocent
people you know if the same thing
happened in the street of London if the
righteous storm the UK Parliament what
will be yoky reaction the UK government
police will sit back and let the things
going on I think any responsible
government has to take measures
[Music]
[Music]
we have a Nobel prize-winning economists
professor Joseph Stiglitz the former
chief executive of BP nor Brown we also
have the economist stephanie kelton a
former adviser to the u.s. Democratic
Party and joining them Stephen Moore a
member of President trumps coronavirus
task force for the economy welcome to
you all
so with jobs finance and economics now
under a strain not felt for many
generations tonight we look at the
future for the economy and the world of
work I was an empty list of people as
far as the eye can see I'm critical care
nurse I've just finished 48 hours of
work there's no fruit there's no
vegetables
consider the impact they're stocking up
might have on others
this is Regent Street home to some of
the biggest names in retail and it's
almost deserted
they're talking about the economy
contracting by 35% that would be the
biggest quarterly for we've ever seen
the UK is facing a significant recession
British Airways are set to make up to
12,000 workers redundant Virgin Atlantic
Airways is to cut more than 3,000 jobs
today
maybe it's shortly being put into
administration unique in modern times
we've never seen anything like this for
the first time in our history the
government is going to step in and help
to pay people's wages f1 cars are out
ventilator trolleys are in the sheer
scale and speed of what's happening here
is clearly a triumph you feel so much
more protected we are seeing the
indomitable spirit of Britain the
estate's online sales are up nearly
2,000 percent there are some fantastic
ideas out there where if we ever get
over this the world has to change
[Music]
what we get in family is audio indirect
to the house people have started cooking
again
but I do think that their British
tourism industry is gonna hit the roof
now we're just going back it would be a
new normal
[Music]
very important question coming up from
one of our virtual audience this is from
amber curry in Oxfordshire
please far away amber thanks for having
me as a recent graduate I'm worried
about how I can enter an industry that
is so reliant on face-to-face contact
I've deferred my Master's as a result of
code at 19 but would I be able to gain
industry experience in the meantime
thank you thank you very much indeed for
that amber very important to joseph
stiglitz we've touched on this already
but let's address it directly this
crisis is generational it's young people
who are not getting training not going
to get jobs to save older people that's
what the statistics tell us about
coronavirus yes we've had a generational
divide exactly been going on for a long
time the one of the problems is their
wages have been stagnant and this has
been particularly true in recent years
and part of the reason is unfettered
capitalism hasn't been working for
ordinary individuals at the bottom the
wages in the United States for instance
are the same as they were 60 years ago
stephanie kelton can I ask you what
we're seeing on the streets of so many
American cities at the moment yes of
course sparked by a racist killing but
we're seeing many many young people in
particular this unemployment is
inequality rife in the United States and
indeed countries like the one I'm in at
the moment is this perhaps one of the
outcomes that we could continue to see
from this crisis I mean people in
distress will take to the streets and
let you know that they are in distress
so at the moment you're right what we're
seeing are a lot of protests that are
being driven by the fact that you know
we continue to see again and again and
again in this country police officers
taking the lives of African Americans
murdering them on the streets we see
these images all the time it's festering
it's coming with the backdrop of kovin
19 where we're all uniquely keenly aware
of the fact that the frontline workers
who bore disproportionately either the
pain associated with job losses income
losses and so forth of people of color
so we see the inequities we see how
unfair this is what you have are blacks
and whites and Latinos and Asian's
Americans and Native people are coming
together to say this is in just all of
it not just the killings but the whole
of the system is rotten and people are
saying we are not going to stand for an
economic and social system that operates
this way in the future Steven Moore well
clearly obviously not to be condoned but
is it understandable when what is
happening on the streets of these
American cities is it understandable is
it well I think the better question is
it justifiable and I think almost
everyone agrees that this criminal
behavior has to stop and I think
President Trump is right that we we have
to stop the rioting and looting it is
outrageous
it is hurting the very people in these
communities that have been afflicted by
you know with low incomes and so on so
it's a horrible thing it's a horrible
thing we're seeing in these in these in
these cities and and frankly I think
Americans are sick and tired of people
apologizing for really radical behavior
that as I said is hurting these very
people who are supposed to be supposed
to be you know benefiting from this now
look we have to America's right now we
have an America of red states that's
what's kind of unique about the United
States that the states really do run the
show and we have red states like Georgia
and Florida and Texas and Tennessee that
are booming absolutely booming have had
twice the rate of growth and twice the
rate of job creation in the last 20
years and then you have these states
like New York and Connecticut New Jersey
in my home state of Illinois and other
states that are run by Democrats that
have been running to the ground and
those are the places where the riots
have been worse so why don't we use the
policies that work lower taxes lower
wrecked I'm not saying we
shouldn't have any regulations I'm
saying we should reward our businesses
for hiring people in doing a great job
and expanding and and look we had a
great economy two and a half months ago
we there was no unemployment there were
six million surplus jobs in this country
it was the best labor market we ever had
we've got to get back to those policies
but know we can never justify violence
and we can never justify people burning
down buildings and and you know
spray-painting obscenities on churches
that's a we can't tolerate because no
one's justifying you know the question
was if we can understand the forces that
they're driving at it just want to bring
amber back in there because amber I saw
you reacting to that and I don't know
what your thoughts were so so share them
with us what you're hearing there I know
I can't speak I'm not an American but it
really seems like it's not about looting
needs to be stopped
okay well thank you for that input amber
and I just want to hear from Lord Brown
and you know let's broaden this out
about young people like amber they're
the seed capital of future Society of
future economies if we get this wrong we
could be in trouble
absolutely we must not get it wrong and
the problem is judging it in the middle
of the turmoil of today where there's a
lot of people without jobs because
there's not a lot of activity but again
I come back to you know building a
different world requires a lot of
different skills and that world will be
different you know just simply the
amount and changing of the way we live
and work what we're doing today on skype
for example will change the demands we
have on infrastructure demands we have
on but how the demands we have a whole
sort of things this will require a lot
more effort want to put out straw poll
to our audience by a show of hands do
you think the cure in the shape of the
economic knockdown could prove worse
than the disease itself hands up if you
think the lockdown
is worse than the virus well that is
just a handful I'd say what three or
four another question for you then
audience I'm just jotting that down
hands up if you think the government's
have generally that have done it that if
you think that governments have
generally lifted lockdown too soon hands
up if you think government's have
generally lifted or started lifting
their lockdowns too soon what do you
think about that even more can I bring
you in here and ask you your view on
that did this have to be done did that
have to be almost global lock downs with
a few exceptions well I can really only
talk about the United States but I think
that what has happened over the last two
or three months in the United States
will go down in history as one of their
greatest economic tragedies and one of
the most biggest political blunders of
our time the idea of shutting down our
economy was a catastrophic decision not
just for our economy but the health
effects of the coronavirus shutdown and
lock down have been arguably worse than
what would have happened if we simply
let people make their own decisions
about whether to go out and I make one
other point we are you you all know that
we are seeing these horrendous riots
around the United States in major cities
these are these riots are a direct
result of the lockdown you can't keep
the American people especially young
people locked in their homes for two or
three months and expect anything but
this and so I think that the the kind of
chaos we're seeing in American cities is
a direct result of a very faulty policy
of locking people in their homes
professor Stiglitz just a quick
rejoinder to that I just have to respond
very strongly the protests in the United
States are a result of police brutality
50 years of police brutality in fact 150
years of police brutality it is a result
of a kind of brutality that has been
flame inflamed by President Trump's this
just rhetoric and that is the reason
that we our country is
burning today
[Music]
[Music]
we're joined by the director of the
Wellcome Trust and a member of the
government Sage committee Sir Jeremy
Farrah Walter got the former
commissioner of the US Food and Drug
Administration the FDA dr. Margaret
Hamburg very good to have you joining
them dr. John and kanga song director of
the Africa Centers for Disease Control
and our quartet is completed with
Professor Dame Sally Davis - former
chief medical officer for England
welcome or so we're the world forced to
confront the biggest health crisis in
generations tonight we look at the
future of science and medicine the
[Music]
corona virus has hit the UK one British
man who likely contracted a virus in
Singapore he then traveled to a French
ski resort then returned from France to
the UK and you don't know the source of
the outbreak and we don't understand its
severity
the first confirmed death in Britain
from coronavirus stay at home protect
our NHS and save lives this used to be a
theater just how much has been canceled
and sacrificed
my wife into allowed to come with me
anymore
miserably these NHS workers who lost
their lives were all at a greater risk
as a community we are put at risk every
single day for a mother then to not be
able to grieve it's unimaginable Allah
and how those deaths halls have grown
World Health Organization now says the
corona virus outbreak is a pandemic NHS
staff are risking their own safety I
understand people's anxieties on the
frontline
don't do something really quickly for
the pair Oh God look deep they are going
to die they want to discharge people but
they don't want to test sometimes I'll
sit in the bath or not I'll cry the
Prime Minister has been taken into an
intensive care unit the NHS has saved my
life
new question
[Applause]
this is a very easy way for me to
support the cause
this is probably the biggest step
forward since the crisis began
government wants to rely on
self-reporting rather than tests so
let's dive straight in let's get our
first question from our audience tonight
this comes from Lindsey Forbes who's on
the Koster blanket in Spain good evening
Lindsey please kick us off with your
question will there be effective vaccine
or is it more likely that we will need
to find effective medical treatments as
was the case with HIV I have another
reason for asking this question the
world leads an effective vaccine but the
fatality rate for the old and
compromised it's frightening lehigh we
need better treatments as soon as
possible so that people are no more
worried about catching calls it than
they are about catching this ok so right
into the meat of it vaccines and short
of that a treatment or treatments let's
kick off with Sir Jeremy fire of n and a
very good evening to you well let's talk
about vaccines first of all we hear
about these well I suppose they're up
into the three figures of testing and
trials and development going on and some
of them are handful a large handful are
now in human trials are you confident
we're going to get a vaccine soon yes
what soon means I don't know and I think
the question that's come is is
absolutely the right question to ask I
was a junior doctor at the start of the
HIV epidemic in the mid 1980s and of
course at that time we also thought we
would have a vaccine I spend a lot of my
life working on tuberculosis and malaria
and the truth is we still don't have
vaccines for those diseases either we
cannot put all of our hopes on a vaccine
doctor and Kangas on very good evening
to you and can I ask you from the
African perspective how high up the
agenda of vaccine development is one
fork ovid 19 presumably it will be more
used to Africa to get one for something
like malaria
absolutely the continent as a whole is
extremely engaged and concerned with
issues related to access to coverage 19
vaccines when they subsequently become
available we always remind ourselves of
what happened in 1996 when HIV
antiretroviral treatment was available
they took so many years before it became
available on the continent of Africa and
so many lives well David I know you're
in Guildford in Surrey would you please
put your question to the panel do you
believe that we still run a serious risk
of a second wave or a future mutation of
kovat 19 medical coding 20 later this
year professor Davis what are your
thoughts on that some say it could go
Koby 19 could go the way of SARS or MERS
saw the coronaviruses that seemed to to
disappear and not come back well so far
the countries that seem to have got rid
of it then still have cases popping up
and while it's rattling round and round
the world that'll be very difficult if
you think about flu it is in the
northern hemisphere then it goes to the
southern it may mutate but then it comes
back round and it just goes round year
after year with different strains and
different changes though I'm not a
forecaster or a modeler I would prefer
to be prepared for a second wave and
even maybe a third wave when we look
back up to 2009 10 the mild flu pandemic
we have three waves and so we can expect
more of this the question is is it a big
wave or is it because of the way we
handle it lots of little waves it'll go
on until we are immune well let's so
reveal some of our polling all week
we've been revealing the results of a
wide-ranging opinion poll that we
conducted for these programs about the
future facing the world now this is one
of the questions we asked will the
pandemic lead to health services in
Britain getting better
or worse and these are the results 43%
of those survey tell us they thought
health services would be better eight
percent thought they would get worse
good evening to you Rach Shonda what
would you like to ask what can we do to
me Anitra stronger right so what can we
do to make our NHS stronger one thing
for sure that will strengthen the NHS is
a preventative strategy you know there
are some wonderful things going on it's
not just the response that these great
staff and all the key workers are making
and we now recognize it's not just
doctors and nurses but we're also seeing
that community care and GP care is now
much more digital we weren't getting
there before and then overnight I'm done
we all like it it's much better
so Jeremy your thoughts on that what are
you seeing what are you hopeful about I
think my most hopeful thing which will
also I'm quite sure happen is that the
interest in this and it's you know it
has captivated the whole scientific
world that will draw into the whole area
of infectious diseases or vaccines of
drug development of immunology all of
the things we have to understand it will
draw another generation of young people
into that just as people were drawn
actually at the start of the HIV
epidemic and and it was those young
people coming into science that actually
provided the answers in the end to the
HIV epidemic and it will be the same
with this pandemic as well when you have
something like this it galvanizes people
funding flows into it from research
agencies and young people come into it
and inevitably it's young people the
disrupt science and provide the benefits
for tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
we consider our society and culture with
us a new live virtual studio audience
once again joining us from around the
world they're going to provide the
questions about how we can build a new
future very welcome to you all now
answering them Nicola Mendelsohn the
vice-president of Facebook in Europe the
Middle East and Africa we'll also got
the musician a professor of poetry
Benjamin Zephaniah the author and
journalist Lionel Shriver who thinks the
lockdown should never have happened
and our quartet tonight his set made up
completed with the astronomer royal and
futurologist professor Rees who says the
fate of future generations will depend
on how we respond to this pandemic very
good evening to you all but before then
we can hear now from the Prince of Wales
who spoken exclusively to our royal
correspondent Rhiannon Mills about his
experience of coronavirus and what life
might be like after the pandemic I
wanted to start off by asking you what
have been your reflections of the the
impact that this pandemic has had on our
country I can't tell you how much I
sympathize with the way everybody has
had to enjoy this unbelievably testing
and challenging time and i-i-i know that
so many people have had the agony of
losing you know their loved ones and the
bewilderment and anxiety that surrounds
everything and so
[Music]
it is the most awful aspect of a
pandemic like this and and yet we've
seen at the same time people being quite
remarkable and wonderful people in
National Health Service and all the
other key workers who've kept everything
going what do you think it is taught us
about our priorities what really matters
in life at the moment we have to put
nature back at the center of everything
we do and put it at the center of our
economy which is before this it's been
nature's has been pushed to the
peripheries we've exploited and dug up
and cut down everything as if there was
no tomorrow if it didn't matter we have
to find a way this time to put nature
back at the center we should have been
treating the planet as if it was a
patient long ago you had the virus
yourself how much did that motivate you
to look at it what can be done next and
where we go forward I was lucky in my
case and and and got away with it quite
likely but I've had it and I cannot say
Oh understand what other people have
gone through in there people are just
desperate see their families already
aren't they it's it's a it's a
challenging time well I mean I haven't
seen my father for a long time he's he's
gonna be 99 next week and so yes all my
grandchildren or anything so I've been
doing but the FaceTime is all very well
how has that been for you being being
disconnected from from your family it's
terribly sad that little n one's friends
but unfortunately released you can speak
to them on telephones and occasionally
do this sort of thing but it isn't the
same is it you want to you really want
to give people a hug the Prince of Wales
there on the stresses that coronavirus
has placed on all families over the last
few months and that chimes with our
first question from our virtual audience
tonight it comes from Natasha Eko Azure
who's in South East London very good
evening to you Natasha and very good
evening to all our audience there
Natasha would you get us started please
with you
question when our social relationships
ever be the same as they were pre kovat
surely everyone has an inner fear or
lack of trust about the people they
interact with from now onwards mmm good
question well I tell you what let's stay
with our audience and let's ask you all
about Natasha's question how many of you
actually agree with that people are now
more mistrustful of people you interact
with now just a show of hands if you
would hands up if you feel more uneasy
about general what used to be everyday
social interactions hands up if you feel
uneasy well well well that's whoo maybe
80% maybe maybe more than 80% nearly
everyone well let's talk to our
panelists then very good evening to you
all Nicola Mendelssohn then and I mean
in a way is that almost music to the
ears of your platform in that people are
they're not gonna meet personally
they're going to interact online so much
of what we're talking about here tonight
as around you know our new world
I certainly hope my new world is one
where people can come together which is
also Natasha's question here how do we
feel about people now I miss people I
haven't seen people in a very long time
and I can't wait to be in a world where
we can interact in the same way as we
once did we're in for a period where we
are going to be still more socially
distance from people but I almost think
that there's a kindness in that because
we're doing that to protect all of us
I'm Benjamin Zephaniah and I should say
that clearly are all our sympathies of
course with George Floyd's
family as memorial services just taking
place is taking place in Minneapolis and
we will be directly addressing that
issue in a moment or two but just just
on this issue of social distancing lack
of social interaction Benjamin Zephaniah
the idea though that people are scared
of interacting with each other well it's
it's natural but we need to I remember a
few years ago I was touring around the
world a very very successful tour I was
in Thailand I was in India I was in
Pakistan I was meeting all these people
Sheikh
their hand was okay but I got to
Malaysia and I met a lady from the
British Council and she was British and
she hopped me and this electricity came
through my body I realize I haven't been
hugged for so long
me personally I am quite nervous about
it just because I know of the reality
let me lay my cards down here I've lost
two members of my family to this Kovac
19 my sister was very close to death and
the day she came out of hospital she
came out from the Saturday morning her
husband went in on the afternoon she got
it very badly physically but he hasn't
recovered mentally because of what he
saw in that hospital and when they tell
me what they went through I think I
don't want to go through that so I can
be a tough guy at trying but I'm pretty
scared right now Benjamin what a
traumatic time for you and your family
our condolences our deepest sympathies
go to you Carolina
Desalle lose who's in reading hello
Carolina what would you like to ask hi
Facebook and Google and other platforms
announced that they would fight fake
news regarding the pandemic shouldn't
these platforms be more accountable for
the concert shares so we are doing a
huge amount and we managed it in a
combination of using Fez of all deep
investments that we've made on machine
learning and artificial intelligence but
also we have over 35,000 people that we
employ around the world but also we need
human review because the Machine still
can't do everything we've always felt
we've had a responsibility to make sure
no real-world harm comes to people
that's incredibly important but actually
the decision making here is coming from
people like the World Health
Organization it's coming from health
ministries from different countries and
other experts we're not experts in this
era we look to others to be able to do
that for us and we're a different sort
of organisation from a traditional
publisher like like sky or like a
newspaper but we are something different
but we do look to independent third
party experts to be able to advise here
well let's get a nervous question from
our virtual already
Raffaello Marioni in north london has a
question good evening Raffaello what
would you like to ask Public Health
England's beam report showed how people
of color had between 10 to 50 percent
higher risk of dying from koba 19 than
white British people compounded by
George Floyd's brutal murder and the
powerful memorial we've just seen is
very clear that institutional racism
still defines countries including our
own as we look to rebuild society after
the pandemic will government and
society's institutions finally and
meaningfully address systemic racism all
black lives continue to not matter well
where do I start
I mean look my mother came to Britain in
1956 and her dream was to work for the
National Health Service and that's what
she did for most of our life most of my
family Oh what we now call frontline
workers up until recently they will call
low paid workers you know when nurses
went on strike for better pay and better
condition they were mean and suddenly
people have got to appreciate what these
people do now we do see that black
people are dying in higher numbers and I
don't quite understand the reasons for
that I understand but we tend to live in
multi-generational homes there is a high
level of diabetes amongst a lot of the
elderly black community but not long ago
there was this whole thing about
Windrush and brexit and sending us home
and all this kind of stuff we were kind
of I mean I used to get racist attacks
in the 70s and 80s and they kind of went
away suddenly they were back I felt like
I was unwanted in my country so I think
that is a kind of perfect storm if you
like this happened recently and they
just said we're gonna get out on the
streets we can't take it anymore things
have got to change and they've got to
change on so many levels
normally agree that not to Prince
Charlie when he talks about nature this
is really really important we have to
change and I speak to the vegan of
relationship with animals and nature and
we have to change our relationships with
ourselves
black lives really do matter and we're
fed up of them not mattering and that is
getting lots of applause unanimous
applause there from our audience thank
you all very much indeed for your input
and your insight this evening and thanks
to of course to everyone in our virtual
studio audience tonight and the 200
audience members we've had across the
week thank you all for taking part and
your questions and your ways very good
night to you thank you very much indeed
[Music]